tricot et graffitis de passion à
première vue éloignée et pourtant à
maurepas le 8 octobre débute une action
de yann bomb in dans le centre ville une
nouvelle forme de street art qui
consiste à décorer le mobilier urbain
avec les techniques du tricot une
initiative pour redonner de la couleur à
nos rues c'est aussi de donner de la
joie et de la bonne humeur avec des
couleurs et de se réapproprier un petit
peu la ville en décorant le mobilier
urbain il ya 50 kg qui ont été tricotée
ça représente à peu près 1000 pilotes se
sont que des restes de dons de dons
aussi de bergère de france quatre mois
de travail ont été nécessaires pour
réaliser cet événement une première à
saint quentin en yvelines dans la
boutique de kathleen on s'affaire à
terminer les derniers détails prêté par
le cyclotourisme club de maurepas ce
vélo a lui aussi le droit d'être
pouponner c'est un adhérent de notre
club qui a prêté gentiment à kathleen
est assez aux personnes qui composent
son atelier un vélo de 50 ans d'âge
que les brodeuses que les tricoteuses
ont habillé de toutes les couleurs dont
le logo de notre club sur les routes on
considère qu'on est on peut être un vrai
acteur du développement du commerce de
proximité en centre ville et c'est
surtout à titre là qu'on a participé à
ce projet un bon bing le vélo sera
installé dans une boulangerie de la
place pendant toute la durée de
l'opération esthétique mais aussi éco
responsable en novembre les ouvrages
seront collectées afin de recycler la
laine en isolation plus de 70 personnes
ont participé à ce tricot graffiti
kathleen espère renouveler l'événement
tous les ans alors à vos aiguilles